in the last 48 hours nearly a thousand
people have died in Lombardy alone the
hospitals are overrun with the sick and
overwhelmed by the dead little can
prepare you for what that looks like but
Sky News was invited to cremone a
hospital to bear witness
Italy's foreign minister has urged the
country to watch our report I repeat he
says stay at home and that is the
direction indefinitely no one knows when
this lockdown will end while the crisis
continues to escalate here in the space
of a month Italy has lost nearly 5,000
of its citizens and they're only the
ones that we know about many elderly are
dying in their homes or in care homes
and aren't recorded in official figures
Alette Ovid Tarlow died at home in
Bergamo last saturday he'd become ill
with a fever and was struggling to
breathe his family all believed they've
had coronavirus was just a Leto who
didn't make it his granddaughter told me
they feared if they took him to hospital
it would be the last time like Italy
Spain is now in national lockdown in a
bid to slow the growing number of cases
the deaths there now rising by hundreds
daily Germany has now imposed its first
lockdown measures two signs on the
pavement telling people to go home while
in eastern France the military are
rushing to build a field hospital by the
end of next week
meanwhile David a Casati who's lost 70
people in his province in the last two
weeks his warning the crisis could be
even greater than we
Italy had lost just one of its citizens
four weeks ago
they're now grieving for nearly 5,000
these pictures can only hint at what
that trauma looks like a trauma they
want no other country to enjoy
Sally Lockwood Sky News Rome